l'actualité du jour c'est le référendum
du pea sur l'unité de la gauche aux
régionales qui a débuté ce matin à 8
heures ces derniers jours le psa il
monte les téléphones c'est des adhérents
avec des sms et des messages enregistrés
de jean christophe cambadelis pour les
inciter à les voler il ya une crainte
d'une faible participation à ce
référendum qui n'ont pas été inondées
ils ont reçu un appel
compte tenu que ça a été envoyé à 5000
exemplaires on peut dire ça inondé cent
mille personnes et 300 fallait chaque
prix d'état aussi un exemplaire c'est
les moyens modernes de communication en
leur disant chère amie va voter
évidemment ils l'ont fait moi j'ai voté
ce matin vous avez voté déjà voté ce
matin oui sûrement espérer qu'on dit
attention sur ma tablette donnera rien
deux cent mille sept cent mille quatre
cent mille cinq cent mille 5000 peu
importe peu importe peu importe le
nombre de votants mais bien sûr ça ne se
réalise pour vous peut importe le nombre
de votants c'est pas le sujet c est ce
que nous sommes capable d'enclencher un
mouvement pour dire oui à l'unité dans
des régions où depuis dix ans voire plus
nous travaillons dans les exécutifs avec
des vice-présidents écolo des vice
présidents communistes des
vice-présidents radicaux de morobe la
vaillance mais non ces deux cas surtout
il n'y a pas une délibération qui n'est
pas votée michael sames par ces
majorités les vice présidents tous les
moyens la prod est réparé ensemble pour
des belges et vous le dire parce qu'ils
confondent les raisons nationales et des
raisons régionales et je le regrette
nous allons faire de la politique
nationale dans ces régionales est-ce que
c'est pas faire porter la responsabilité
aux autres partis de gauche d'une
défaite dont le ps n'aurait également
être responsable c'est faire porter la
responsabilité aux autres partis de
gauche de leur incurie à faire la
différence entre la politique nationale
la politique régionale
ils sont responsables de leurs décisions
et ils sont responsables camps dans le
nord pas de calais responsables de la
défense n'ont pas du tout pas du tout
les défaites de la gaule alréenne houle
a construit un de vous dire non
la défaite de la gauche sera défaite des
candidats de gauche moi je ne dis pas
ils seront responsables à des faibles je
pense qu'ils sont responsables de la
situation d'aujourd'hui en mélangeant
nationales et régionales et notamment
moi j'ai voulu dire dans une région où
l'extrême droite est aux portes de la
gouverner de dire cela mais ce n'est pas
grave
d'entendre le parti de gauche de jean
luc mélenchon de dire toute façon on ne
votera pas pour la gauche pour les
socialistes deuxième tour
voilà c'est fait on ne fait pas la
différence entre marine le pen et la
gauche
autre sujet de l'autre actualité du jour
c'est la déclaration de candidature de
jean yves le drian en bretagne alors le
ministre de la défense est très apprécié
à la fois par les militaires et par
françois hollande et par l'exécutif
qu'est ce qui va se passer en cas de
victoire est ce que vous souhaitez qui
restent mises de la défense d'abord il
faut être heureux qu'un ministre est
apprécié par la gauche et par la droite
c'est très serré c'est très bon oui mais
c'est rare mais c'est très important
il est très apprécié c'est un très bon
ministre il fait le choix de s'engager
en bretagne parce qu'il est très
apprécié aussi en bretagne par la droite
et par la gauche et par les gens de la
bretagne
donc il a fait la conférence de presse
ce matin les choses sont claires il n'y
a aucun problème j'entendais le
président des républicains a semblé dire
on peut pas être ministre et candidat
enfin il se rappelle pas que alain juppé
était lui-même maire de bordeaux est
premier ministre
ce sera le choc devrait au final de ce
sera aux joies de jean yves le drian de
jean yves le drian
il fera le choix le 13 décembre au soir
entre sa région et le ministère mais
comme il l'a très bien dit ce matin dans
sa conférence de presse évidemment il
n'y aura pas de passe-droit il est
remplaçable n'y aura pas de passe-droit
ce ne sera pas le choix de françois
hollande bien si je suppose qu'ils en
parleront ya en tout cas sur ce sujet
une jurisprudence qui est celle de
françois rebsamen plus que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous lui avez
sextuplé à la tête du groupe ps au sénat
alors il a dû quitter justement le
gouvernement pour rejoindre sa mairie de
dijon on a l'impression qu'il a assez
mal vécu cet épisode dans un livre des
journalistes henri vernet et renaud dély
qui sort cette semaine qui consacrait à
la violence en politique
françois rebsamen dit françois hollande
n'a pas d'affect ce type est un galet et
vous les voyez comme ça aussi
non ça hollande de françois hollande est
quelqu'un qui est dur parce qu'il faut
être dur lorsqu'on est président de la
république il faut pas tremblé à chaque
à chaque prise de décision ou se mettre
aux abris lorsqu'on se fait attaquer
petit a lâché 7 il faut changer de
métier n'a jamais lâché ses proches
françois hollande et d'une dureté
incroyable est indispensable pour gérer
le pays
mais il n'est pas dur avec ses relations
la phrase que vous citez de françois
rebsamen
elle aurait été prononcée d'après ce que
a dit l'intéressé il y a quatre ans donc
en parle pas de la presse du quinquennat
tandis qu'au final françois hollande
n'est pas un président seul
aujourd'hui françois hollande est un
président qui a des difficultés en
termes de cote de popularité est un
président qui restera dans l'histoire
parce que malgré les difficultés il aura
réformé il aura et formés dans le sens
de la justice sociale
il aura fait des réformes qui touchent
le plus grand nombre et non seulement il
n'est pas seul mais moi qui étais à deux
types de soutien non mais moi qui était
avec lui lorsqu'il était à 3%
aujourd'hui il a 25 ans 26% ça fait
plaisir de démarrer cette hauteur là
donc on a réussi il a réussi à être élu
président de la république apr 23 % je
ne doute pas qu'ils réussirent à avoir
un tel outil à se faire réélire
président important de 25
vous êtes l'un des rares à avoir un tel
optimisme vis-à-vis de françois hollande
parce que moi j'ai une d'avenir
politique oui parce que moi je ne
cherche pas à faire des petites phrases
à avoir des dépêches afp ou à passer sur
les plateaux venant de quelqu'un ayant
des choses quand on dit les choses qui
vont bien ben voilà c'est comme ça
nous vivons mieux je vise personne je
dis il vaut mieux dire du mal pour se
faire entendre
moi je dit du bien j'ai une si j'ai des
choses à dire je les dis à l'intéressé
jeudi au président de la république mais
je pense vraiment que la politique menée
par un président de la république et
prémunissent va dans le bon sens elle
est dur à expliquer il faut aller sur le
terrain et que tout le monde se
consacrent aller sur le terrain est lui
en 2012 et faire des bons goûts qui sera
réélu en 2010 est selon j'espère qu'il
le sera mais dieu merci merci